we it's a take off one or two cells from  a multi cell embryo after been  fertilized and grown for a couple days  and determine is it a boy or girls that  have I so meet their twenty-one  showdowns but now what happens when you  can select for sex or for eye color or  for intelligence so that's already on  the slippery slope of genetic ethics now  it's already been shown in the science  world that you can modify embryos with  CRISPR cast nine in in at that stage so  I believe it's still sort of a legal in  the global sense but there's the  possibility to start manipulating and  optimizing or fixing ideally fixing any  vector minimally it should not be  illegal to fix things that are gonna  influence suffering on somebody's life  if we don't fix